thank you um thank you for uh
the invitation to speak i'm going to
talk about um
sample a starved situation where you
have
an objective to estimate certain
properties of a correlation matrix in a
very high dimensional setting
and i'm going to motivate this by some
applications
uh to please uh david
and then i'm going to jump into
some mathematical results
and talk about one of the principal
ideas that comes out of this type of
approach this type of formulation of the
correlation mining problem which is
multi-stage online multi-stage uh
sampling prediction adaptive regression
using correlation screening
so this is work that i've
had lots of help with over the years
and these are some of the the sponsors
and students that have helped me with
this so
here are the applications for david
thank you thank you yeah so uh i've
worked many years on uh trying to
extract uh relationships dependency
relationships correlation
non-linear correlation from different
types of high dimensional data like gene
expression
email spam networks
social data social networks microscopy
where you have images with very high
dimensional features
and and different types of problems and
tracking and the the uh objective in all
of these has been to construct some sort
of graphical model if you like that
captures uh the relationships between
variables the problem is that you have
lots of variables and you only have
relatively few samples in these
situations for example in
looking at
coming up with these molecular pathway
networks which are basically thresholded
uh sample correlation or sample partial
correlation uh you have to form uh an
estimate of the overall correlation
matrix uh threshold at some value or
use an optimization approach such as g
lasso or or some other uh
approach that
approaches this from the maximum
likelihood framework and then construct
a hopefully reliable network of
relationships and codependencies between
the variables
so
the
process of going from data like these 20
sequences 20 variables with 15 samples
each
to the sample correlation
matrix which of course is only going to
have a rank 20 here if we have 20
variables
to then a thresholding of that sample
correlation matrix where you can extract
things like hub degree
of the of the graph as uh interpreted as
say the sixth variable here being
correlated at some level say greater
than 0.5 in magnitude with some other
variables and so in this case we have
a degree 2 that
might be of some significance either
biologically
or in other applications like spam
networks
associated with the the uh uh perhaps
the person or person's in control of the
of the influence network and then you
can construct graphs like this where the
edges of course correspond to
non-zero entries in this thresholded
sample correlation matrix
the problem here is that uh again we
have relatively uh
small number of samples uh to do
inference uh to construct this type
these types of graphs uh and a very
large number of unknowns right in the in
the gene expression example there might
be 20 to 30 000
genes in the genome uh in the uh spam
example you might have
millions of ip addresses right so on the
other hand you only have relatively few
samples because they're expensive
so it's a crucial need to manage
uncertainty and to look for
controlling false positives and this is
what led us
early in the in
in this work to start to ask questions
about
how can we characterize reliability
of
these types of correlation inferences
uh based on observational data like the
ones that i was talking about a minute
ago you know gene expression and and
spam traffic and so forth
so um this is a real problem and this is
a very nice paper that came out of a
article in significance the magazine
of the journal of the royal society of
statistics
in
2011
where
they looked at 14 different paper 14
different studies i should say
and
these studies were published in very
high profile journals like lancet and
the journal of american medical
association and each one of these uh
articles basically followed up on those
studies proving that either the
claims in those studies based on
correlation between
variables that were used in the
experimental design to come up with for
example
a conclusion that
treatment with more vitamin e or
beta-carotene will reduce your chance of
lung cancer if you're a smoker were
actually specious and and uh
did not replicate in a much larger trial
so the problem here is the absence of
adequate uh
control of these false positives or
spurious correlations
and it's again a real problem so
what what we we did to approach this
problem was we looked at the literature
we found lots of results in the
literature on correlation estimation
model selection
and you know
looking at
various types of consistency results
sign consistency to recover the right
sign of the correlation matrix and so
forth and all of these uh methods were
based on uh one or two very limiting
assumptions of course if you go far far
back you know 20 or 30 years
it was all based on having a
a finite and small
size of of of the matrix that has few
variables and lots of samples which is
not appropriate to uh most of the
applications that uh that we're dealing
with
and then there were another uh more
recent results of which they uh have the
regime where both p and n p the number
of variables and n are going off to
infinity at various rates
um but they're both going off to
infinity and so our uh our approach was
to say well let's see what we can do
when n is fixed this is a different
regime if you like that
that we're exploiting and we came up
with some results in that a few years
ago and i'm going to show you some of
those here and show and try if i have
enough time to
indicate some of the implications on
doing this type of
correlation analysis for prediction so
here's just some some math to get us to
get us going so that you understand the
theorem uh uh and that uh is that we
have some measurement matrix
p by n that's a typo uh we're number of
variables by number of samples
with columns
corresponding to the vector of variables
sampled independently and
with identical distribution we assume
that the covariance matrix is of course
now a p by p matrix it's sparse row
sparse
or block sparse
and of course that means that the
correlation matrix the normalized
coherence matrix is also sparse
and it has some adjacency matrix a0
which is simply the hard thresholding at
uh uh
at any level uh a threshold row of the
entries of this sparse correlation
matrix uh and we can define the support
set of connectivity that's uh you know
the rows of the of the adjacency matrix
that have more than uh well that have
any number of of uh entries uh uh that
is from uh degree one to uh you know
degree up to p minus one and the hub
degree is of course the number of uh of
non-zero entries in that corresponding
uh row and you look therefore at the
rows that have a hub degree of greater
than or equal to delta and that gives
you the delta support set so we're gonna
give results for these uh
various uh uh discovering uh these uh
these sets with with accuracy so the p
by p sample covariance matrix is simply
uh uh constructed by uh projecting onto
the orthogonal to the
the one-dimensional
space of constant vectors this matrix uh
and forming the quadratic form of that
you get the p by b sample correlation
matrix which corresponds to
an estimate now a rank deficient
estimate estimate because n is going to
be much less than p
of the
ensemble or population correlation
matrix
sigma and then it of course has its own
adjacency metrics if you if you
threshold at some correlation level row
and uh you can estimate the connectivity
support for example at that level row
but
clearly
we're going to end up with in practice
some false positives so we're going to
have to carefully choose this
this row so that
we can
in support recovery or correlation
screening as we call it
control either the misclassification
errors on the support uh in the
connectivity support of the uh that has
the variables that have some uh
correlation to other variables at that
level row in the sample correlation or
partial correlation matrix inverse of
the correlation
or
the probability that we get any
such
variables that have connectivity given
that this
covariance matrix is very sparse the
true covariance matrix is very sparse
and has no
connectivity at level of threshold row
on the on the population covariance
so if we define n row as the number of
discoveries above the threshold
we end up with uh false positives uh
that because naturally uh we're in this
regime of high sample variability and so
this is what i was saying at the
beginning with these regimes of sample
rich where the central limit theorem
applies uh where uh you know uh we have
p
uh is uh
uh uh is fixed and then is going to
infinity uh we have the sample critical
regime which fits these uh uh
semi-circle and marcin called pasteur
types of of results where you can't uh
uh estimate with any accuracy the uh
the covariance matrix or a spectrum but
you can you can estimate the maximal um
eigenvalue or estimate the distribution
i should say of the maximalized
eigenvalue if n and p go to infinity
this at the same uh linear uh related
rate and then the so-called sample
starved regime where n is fixed and p
goes to infinity so this is the regime
that we're really interested in
and
it governs uh this what we call purely
high dimensional asymptotics this is a
kind of a new regime because we're we're
letting p go to infinity n is fixed now
you might think that there's some voodoo
here because uh you can't
obviously allow p go to infinity and fix
n without allowing something else to to
vary because you will end up with uh
trivial results where uh you you have uh
all your discoveries or false positives
unless you allow some other parameter to
vary and that parameter is effectively
this this threshold that we're going to
apply and so here's what we do
this shows
a simulation of a
set of variables there are a hundred of
them
with
a diagonal covariance matrix so there's
no dependency all
all positives are false positives in
terms of the edge discoveries it's any
value of correlation threshold row and
so if we have 101 uh this just so barely
above the number of variables uh of
observations
we can see that there is a very abrupt
uh increase in the number of false
positives as we bring this correlation
threshold below this critical threshold
which i call rho c which is about 0.34
so that means that if you set the
threshold below this value you're going
to be overwhelmed with false positives
right and this is a this is a simulation
so it it applies to cases where uh n and
p are finite obviously because that's
how we've set the problem up if you
reduce the number of observations this
correlation uh critical threshold
increases it creeps up until you're
really between a rock and a hard place
here where there's really no
margin for true positives right
everything becomes a false positive up
here uh when you only have a tenth of
the uh uh of the variables available to
do uh uh to to do edge discovery or uh
screening
so um
the uh
region of reliability is is within this
margin between 1 and the correlation
threshold this critical threshold
given the theory i'm going to show you
on the next slide can be determined
for large p
by this expression which you can see for
large n
p to the power minus one over n behaves
roughly as logarithmic in p right so
this threshold creeps up very slowly if
you have large n
uh if n is much larger than p uh you
know the uh by increasing p uh you only
get a logarithmic increase in the
correlation threshold so that's the
that's the part of the space if you like
of n p
where you're in the classical regime
where everything's stable where
increases in p can be accommodated uh
with uh
basically only a logarithmic penalty
yeah okay remind me what's the end again
cn is a is a constant that is related to
the underlying distribution of the so
the cor the true correlation the true
covariance the population covariance so
i haven't defined cn here
yeah so that's why you don't know what
it is uh but yeah that's a good sign yes
it's hidden in this big o so
if that uh so it's it's related to the
uh uh the the packing number of the
space and
uh is given by uh a
so see it depends on the
underlying distribution it does inc
except for the case where you have a
sparse covariance
so if the if the number of rows that
have a degree
greater than than zero
is of little o p
then that c n becomes independent
of the of the of the true underlying
covariance and that's key because that
allows one to uh determine false
positive rates uh without knowing the
underlying distribution so what is ca
for this example where the covariance is
identity yeah so for that particular
case cn is equal to
the
uh incomplete beta function
where uh the integral from row to one of
the incomplete complete beta function so
it's completely tabulated and you can
determine cn yeah
so this is the theorem um uh and this
goes back to a paper in for information
theory that we published in 2012
um and so it says and i haven't given
all the assumptions here but uh if you
start out with uh
assumption that the the columns of the
matrix x are iid and each uh column has
a bounded elliptically contoured density
with a row sparse covariance
okay so rosbar simply means that the
degrees
of of the true
correlation
uh
graph is
uh fixed and finite upper bounded i
should say right it's not a regular
graph it's a but it's it's uh uh upper
bounded strictly upper bounded and
then you get the following result if you
allow the correlation threshold which i
showed oops which i showed here to creep
up at exactly the rate at which uh this
knee
uh that is this critical threshold
creeps up then what you can do is you
can maintain as you increase p
for fixed n you can maintain
the same expected number of
uh
if you want to call them false positives
right
they will be false positives for
sufficiently large row because i've
assumed that the distribution is bounded
so there's no perfectly correlated
variables right so there is some upper
some some upper bound on the true
correlation
so um this looks like a limit
that uh
should remind uh those in the audience
who are familiar with the poisson law of
how a poisson random variable this being
the number of false positives at uh
of
variables that
have
a degree greater than or equal to delta
at a correlation level rho um that the
the false positive has a probability
that behaves in this way where lambda is
the rate of a poisson function a plus
one is a plus on the variable
um it's not poisson though because i
mean for the case delta equals one
connectivity is a mutual mutually
symmetric relation so uh clearly
n cannot be an odd number right so can't
be poisson but it turns out that this
probability behaves like a poisson
variable
okay so as i said this here's the this
is actually cn right here
that's the expression for cn and we can
look at the phase transition threshold
uh that comes right out of this theory
uh as the point at which that knee
occurs is measured by the point in row
uh where the uh
the slope is equal to minus one and what
you see uh is that as a as a function
the number of observations uh and the uh
minimum detectable correlation which is
the critical uh
uh threshold uh it it decreases and it
decreases extremely quickly
for a few observations as you get a very
large number of observations where
you're now going to this classical
regime it decreases much more slowly so
what this means is is that there's
actually a kind of a blessing of
dimensionality here as opposed to a
curse of dimensionality in that just a
small increase in the number of
observations if you don't have very much
to begin with can give you a significant
decrease in the critical uh threshold
which means that now you can discover
with higher
confidence uh
a larger uh with high confidence i
should say a larger region of of uh true
correlations think the colored code is
not showing up but it's not showing up
unfortunately here is one
too many many many zeros yeah so blue
blue here
is 10 billion right see this is for 10
billion variables you only need you know
on the order of about
a 200
observations to have a critical phase
transition threshold of about 0.6
which is very
you know very surprising but of course
in this regime here
you can't discover everything right you
can't discover all the edges but you can
ensure that
the false positive probability of
discovering any edge or of stating that
the
correlation matrix has
some edges that that can be controlled
at this level of 0.01 which is this uh
this just to get a sense of this point
is high good about
high is bad right right because the
correlation
is more detectable
exactly so it's bad as of course as you
increase the number of variables the
better you are yeah i mean this is the
slope
right it's the slope so
the slope is really really high down
here so if you have small n the benefit
the value increasing the number of
samples is larger than it is out here so
in the classical regime
there's not much benefit increasing in
increasing the samples by a little bit
whereas in a low dimensional regime
there is a a great advantage right and
this just shows that so this is uh this
shows the
uh uh
a comparison if you like between these
asymptotic regimes
for what we call screening which is with
the theory i've just given you here the
support recovery in the covariance
estimation cases uh where the error
criteria are different um and uh you can
characterize the um
these particular regimes is
corresponding to
either order one the number of
observations uh uh increases the
complexity for the sample complexity is
basically order one
in the case of screening as long as you
increase the threshold at that rate
right so that you maintain a constant
number of uh false positives uh as
opposed to uh forcing in to increase at
least log p rate uh if you fix the
critical phase thresh threshold uh at
rho star
and then covariance estimation you have
p log p for for the sparse case so we're
in this regime where um uh we call we
call it the purely high dimensional
regime where n is is fixed and p goes to
infinity but we uh control the uh
the critical phase transition threshold
so what this res this suggests
is that uh
you have if you have the ability to
collect data
in an online fashion you should do so in
a progressive stage-wise manner because
take advantage of these regimes
take advantage of these regimes in
screening you can uh you're in this this
order one regime so
you can you can look at a few samples
say of a very large um
number of variables if you're doing for
example discovery in the uh properties
of of the gene expression you could
do assays with the full
genome but a few observations do
screening then for until you can uh be
reliably uh sure that n is large enough
at that with that fiddle
critical phase transition threshold that
you have biologically significant edges
say
rho equals 0.5
and then uh
use down sampling of the uh of the
variables to focus in on those that pass
the screen to do support
recovery and then follow that by
estimation as the sample size increases
so it's progressive correlation mining
makes sense because you're making use of
this table of progressively harder and
harder tasks requiring more and more
samples in order to do that
so i'm not going to have time to go into
these results here other than say this
this is uh this this sparks procedure
does two stages it does screening at one
stage
reduces the number of variables uh uh
according to the guarantees the false
positive family-wise error guarantees uh
to select or a pre-screen a small set of
variables and then
perform ordinary least squares on those
variables this is similar to
fan and love's
sure independent screening except here
we will do the correlation screening
directly on the
regular regression coefficients as
opposed to on the
unnormalized marginal uh correlations
so
we have some guarantees and some proof
of convergence and sample complexity and
showing that we improve significantly
over uh sure independent screening and
lasso in this progressive
type of
correlation mining task of in this case
predicting a response variable and then
some real data that's
uh that i don't have time to talk about
where the response variable that we're
trying to predict is a symptom it's a
phenotype of a population given
a set of
a gene chip measurements alphametrics
gene ship measurements
so in conclusion um i i hope that i've
uh
uh
gotten the idea across that we're
looking at this purely high dimensional
setting which is different from what the
the the very high dimensional or ultra
high dimensional or other types of of
dimensional high dimensional settings
are where n and p are allowed to go into
infinity uh that we have universal phase
transition thresholds that apply to this
case of n fixed uh while p goes to
infinity and that these phase
transitions can be very useful for doing
this sort of multi-stage uh sizing right
sizing of the sample
as you progressively go through
down selecting the variables to assay
there's a lot of things i haven't
covered here we've done a lot of work
in structured covariance
in generalizing this to non-linear
correlation mining
and spectral correlation mining where
you have random processes that you're
trying to find the uh
the coherency function or coherency
matrix using uh similar types of
correlation screening types of
approaches
and then i'll leave you just with some
references that
uh if you're interested in following up
on you can take a look at
thank you
i have a question so i want to
understand better how universal this
method
is the political money for example if i
don't know your model exactly right how
can i compute this
exact this critical threshold things
like that or if i know the model
slightly wrong or very wrong with that
significant impact
good question so the only assumption
here
is that we have this elliptically
contoured density
with a bounded a bounded density and
uh this sparse sparsely constraint so if
you're guaranteed that the the the
correlation matrix or the dispersion
matrix and your elliptically contoured
density
is sparse it doesn't matter what the
entries are in the in the component the
active variables right so it's very
robust in that sense to the values of
the correlations
uh within the sparse correlation matrix
of course not robust if you don't have a
sparse correlation matrix then these
results will no longer apply do you want
me to know the level of sparsity
right so you don't it turns out that
under these regimes all all you have to
be all you have to guarantee is that
it'd be smaller order of p
so there's no uh no need to know what
the sparsity levels are
yeah of course there's a constant out in
front which also depends on
on the sparsity and that's uh so you
know if
we we can't guarantee uh you know the uh
for
p small
but for p very large that constant
basically becomes independent of the
structure of the correlation
thank you for the question
thank you